STEPPING UP WITH MAJOR
INVESTMENT IN JOBS AND WAGES
AFTER THAT TAX CUT PASSED,
SEAN.
>> Sean: BUSY DAY AS YOU
KNOW.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: ALSO TODAY IN
PENNSYLVANIA THE PRESIDENT
REMINDED THE COUNTRY HIS
POSITION ON SECURING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER WAS NOT
CHANGED ONE BIT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE WALL HAS BEEN
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE BEEN
VERY CONSISTENT ON, ALWAYS.
AND AS YOU KNOW, IN FACT IN
AN INTERVIEW WITH YOU, I
SAID THE WALL, YOU DON’T
NEED A WALL WHERE YOU HAVE A
MOUNTAIN.
YOU NEED A WALL -- EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT I HAVE BEEN
SAYING THAT FOR THREE YEARS.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
BUT A WALL IS NOT
NECESSARILY A WALL WHERE YOU
HAVE A MOUNTAIN.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS IT.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION
IS THE CO-HOST OF THE FIVE
AND THE HOST OF "WATTERS’
WORLD," IT’S HIS WORLD WE
LIVE IN IT HOW DO YOU DO IT.
>> Jesse: YOU DID IT VERY
WELL.
>> Sean: I BUSTED UP MY
KNUCKLES.
JESSE WATTERS AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JESSICA TARLOV
IS WITH US.
>> CAN I GET A HAND SIGNAL?
>> YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
THAT.
>> SHE HAS GOT IT ALL WRONG.
>> Sean: THIS IS HANNITY’S
WORLD NOW.
JUST FOR A FEW MOMENTS.
JUST GIVE US A LITTLE SPACE.
ALL RIGHT.
WE ARE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
POLITICAL FOOTBALLS USING
THE DREAMERS HERE.
THIS IS ONE MONTH EXTENDING
AND THE -- EITHER GIVE US
EVERYTHING WE WANT.
WE DON’T HAVE CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE OR SENATE OR WE’RE
GOING TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> WELL, MAYBE GET THE VOTES
ON THEIR OWN?
>> Sean: WHAT?
>> SHOULDN’T THEY BE ABLE TO
GET THE VOTES ON THEIR OWN.
51, 49 IS NOT EXACTLY THE
BIG COMFORTABLE MARGIN THAT
YOU WOULD WANT.
>> STILL A MAJORITY.
>> Sean: OKAY.
SO THE POINT IS THEY ARE
USING --
>> -- NO THEY ARE NOT.
>> Sean: AS A POLITICAL
FOOTBALL BECAUSE THEY CAN’T
GET WHAT THEY WANT.
>> THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO RUN
ON THE SIDES OF ILLEGAL
ALIENS, THAT’S FINE.
LET THEM RUN ON IT WE WILL
RIDE ON THE SIDE OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
I THINK YOU GUYS DON’T WANT
TO DIE ON THAT HILL.
IT’S NOT SMART POLITICS AND
HARD MEN AND WORKING PEOPLE
OF THIS COUNTRY AREN’T GOING
TO BUY IT.
>> MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
DON’T SEE THESE DREAMERS AS
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
>> TAKE CARE OF THE DREAMERS
BUT THOUGHT THE EXPENSE OF
THE U.S. MILITARY.
>> WELL, I DON’T THINK
THAT’S WHAT WE -- THE
DECISION THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SHEAR.
THAT’S HOW PEOPLE HAVE SET
UP IT AS JUXTAPOSITION
THAT’S ISN’T WHAT IS GOING
ON HERE.
DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT TO
CONTINUE PUNTING THIS DOWN
THE LINE.
IN A MONTH THIS WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN.
>> Sean: CHILDREN IN THEIR
20’S AND 30’S BUT ALSO WANT
CHAIN MIGRATION TO CONTINUE
AND THEY WANT THEIR FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO COME.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE ASKING
FOR.
>> THEY WANT UNCLE LEO AND
AUNT NETTY.
THE DEAL IS THEY DON’T WANT
THE WALL.
>> BINGO.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE WALLS WORK.
THAT’S WHY THEY DON’T WANT
IT BECAUSE YOU GUYS NEED NEW
VOTERS.
>> AS GENERAL KELLY SAID
LAST NIGHT WITH BRET BAIER,
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE
THAT PROMISE, HE WAS
UNINFORMED.
HE HAS EVOLVED ON THE ISSUE.
IT USED TO BE A SOLID WALL.
NOW IT HAS HOLES.
>> NO ONE IS GOING TO BUT
THE A WALL ON THE RIO
GRANDE.
THAT’S WHERE THE ALLIGATORS
ARE GOING TO BE.
ALL RIGHT?
THAT’S GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
EVERYTHING.
>> Sean: WHO SAID THE
ALLIGATOR?
THE MOAT.
>> THE MOAT.
THAT’S PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA.
WHO VOTED TO FUND THE WALL
BY THE WAY.
>> Sean: THAT’S THE THING.
FIVE YEARS AGO, EVERY MAJOR
DEMOCRAT SOUNDED LIKE DONALD
TRUMP TODAY.
FIVE YEARS AGO THEY WANTED
TO BUILD THE WALL.
NOW IT’S RACIST AND HORRIBLE
AND WE’RE KILLING THE
CHILDREN.
WHY -- HOW DO YOU GET AWAY
WITH THAT HYPOCRISY, NOT
YOU, SCHUMER AND ALL THE
REST OF THEM, DURBIN?
>> CRYING CHUCK YOU MEAN.
>> DON’T CALL HIM THAT AND I
DON’T LIKE THIS TURBAN
DURBIN OR DICKEY DURBIN.
>> Sean: WHAT ARE YOU
CALLING HIM?
THAT’S NOT NICE.
>> CLEAN IT UP.
>> IF YOU ARE WATCHING I DID
NOT SAY THAT.
>> WHAT IN THIS MEDIA ITE
EVERY NIGHT ON THIS PROGRAM.
>> I TAKE IT BACK.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
CONSISTENT ON THIS ALL
SPOKEN OUT FOR BORDER
SECURITY IT’S PART OF THE
GANG OF EIGHT BILL.
>> Sean: THEY WANTED 700
PLUS MILES OF WALL FIVE
YEARS AGO.
>> THINGS ARE DIFFERENT NOW.
WHEN YOU SAY THEY USE THE
SAME LANGUAGE THEY DIDN’T.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> CROSS THE BORDER AND
KILLING DEPUTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT’S WHAT’S
DIFFERENTIAL.
>> OUTFLOW OF IMMIGRANTS
FROM THE SOUTHERN BORDER OUT
OF THIS COUNTRY.
YOU CAN’T DENY THOSE ARE THE
NUMBERS.
>> SO PEOPLE AREN’T CROSSING
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE THE BORDER
PATROL CATCHES A THOUSAND
PEOPLE CROSSING EACH DAY.
THAT’S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> THE TOTAL NUMBERSES ARE A
NET OUTFLOW.
THE PROBLEM IS NOT NEARLY AS
SEVERE.
>> Sean: THAT’S A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
>> PRETTY SEVERE IF YOU ARE
TALKING A THOUSAND A DAY.
>> Sean: I SAT THROUGH A
SECURITY BRIEFING WITH
GOVERNOR RICK PERRY.
I HAVE BEEN DOWN TO THE
BORDER 12 TIMES.
RIO GRAND, SAN DIEGO, DRUG
WAREHOUSES, HELICOPTER,
HORSEBACK, ALTER WANE
VEHICLES, BOATS, YOU NAME
IT.
I WAS IS THERE WENT WITH
THEM.
ALSO SAW TUNNELS.
I WAS IN TUNNELS THAT WERE
DUG.
THE AMOUNT OF DRUGS IS
INSANE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY WHEN I SAT
THROUGH THE SECURITY
BRIEFING, 642,000 TEXANS
WERE VICTIMS OF CRIMES BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS IN THE A
SEVEN AND A HALF YEAR PERIOD
OF TIME.
NOW, WAIT A MINUTE, DO YOU
CARE ABOUT THEM?
>> YEAH, OF COURSE I DO.
WE TALKED ABOUT KATE STEINLE
AND HER MURDER.
>> Sean: WHY DON’T WE PUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST
AND AS PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
WE WILL PUT A DOOR INSIDE
THE WALL.
>> I KNOW THE GOLD DOOR.
>> Sean: I DIDN’T SAY GOLD.
PLATINUM WORKS.
>> HE LOVES GOLD.
>> PUT A KEY ON IT.
>> YOU MADE ME LOSE MY
THOUGHT.
>> 642,000.
>> THE POINT IS WALLS WORK
YOU DON’T WANT IT BECAUSE
YOU GUYS NEED NEW VOTERS.
IT’S A DANGEROUS SITUATION
DOWN THERE ON THE BORDER.
ASK ANY RANCHER.
THEY ARE BRINGING GUNS.
THEY’RE BRINGING DRUGS.
SOME OF THEM ARE GOOD
PEOPLE.
>> WHY ARE THEIR TEXAS
G.O.P. REPRESENTATIVES THAT
SAY THAT THEY DON’T WANT THE
BORDER WALL AND IT’S NOT THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAVE TO DO
IT?
>> ONE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT THE DEMOCRATS DON’T
WANT TO SPEND MONEY ON.
>> IT’S A FENCE NOW.
I AM COMPLETELY.
>> Sean: HANG ON.
>> BECAUSE WHO IS GOING TO
PAY FOR IT?
>> Sean: BRILLIANT LINE IN
THIS WORLD.
WE ARE LIVING IN IT?
>> THAT WAS YOUR WORLD.
>> Sean: I DON’T HAVE A
WORLD.
>> THIS IS 9:00.
IT’S YOUR WORLD.
>> Sean: THAT’S TRUE 9 TO
10:00.
YOU HAVE GOT THAT WATERS
THIS IS MY WORLD.
>> CAN YOU HAVE IT.
>> Sean: THANK YOU BOTH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: I DON’T CARE IF THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTS DOWN
BECAUSE ALL ESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEES WORK.
EVERYONE IS GOING TO GET
THEIR CHECKS.
THE MILITARY KEEPING
WORKING.
>> YOU KNOW REPUBLICANS